[Música]
Hola bienvenidos al debate de France 24
soy Santiago López González hay división
de opiniones en Bolivia en torno a las
medidas y a las restricciones impuestas
o levantadas ya recientemente por parte
de las autoridades del país para hacer
frente a la pandemia del Coby 19 sobre
todo hay discrepancias al reciente
levantamiento de esa medida que habían
puesto el gobierno de hacer uso de un
pase sanitario para poder movilizarse a
lo largo de ancho del país ante el
reciente repunte de casos debido a la
variante o micron que tiene ese país
suramericano en una alerta desde el
pasado mes de diciembre como lo decía el
foco de la controversia radicó en esa
obligatoriedad a partir del primero de
enero demostrar el certificado de
vacunación para ingresar a los espacios
públicos lo que provocó protestas de
diferentes sectores de la sociedad
boliviana y la medida fue postergada
para entrar en vigor el 26 de enero sin
embargo el ministro de salud de Bolivia
Jason ausa Indicó que la exigencia del
documento ha cumplido con su objetivo y
suspendió la obligatoriedad de presentar
Este certificado que debía entrar el 26
de enero pero ya no va a ser así la
controversia se da en momentos en que en
Bolivia se está presentando un alto
número de casos como lo mencionaba y hay
pugnas políticas al interior del partido
de gobierno el movimiento al socialismo
en el debate de France 24 daremos
entonces un vistazo a esas disputas que
se están presentando en este país
Bolivia entre omicron y los anti vacunas
Ese es nuestro tema de debate para esta
jornada y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a Fernando Romero él es el
máximo dirigente del sindicato médico de
la ciudad de la paz también está con
nosotros un weddie Ramiro Cordero Él es
médico cirujano de la universidad mayor
de San Andrés también está en la ciudad
de la paz ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales nos encuentran en Facebook en
Instagram y en Twitter estamos como
arroba
france24_es y @santilogo que es mi
cuenta personal de recuerdo la etiqueta
es numeral el debate f24 esperamos sus
comentarios y todas sus opiniones en
torno a este tema que hoy nos lleva
hasta Bolivia comienzo entonces con
Fernando Romero ya lo decíamos él está
en la ciudad de la paz y comienzo
preguntándole por la coyuntura más
reciente el gobierno le parece a usted
que el gobierno boliviano se dio
ante la presión de los grupos antivacuna
o ante experimento o personas que están
en contra de la vacunación obligatoria
en este país
pero pasa que como tú bien dijiste el
país tiene miles de casos por día de
esta cuarta hora de enfermedad los
hospitales están llenos de pacientes al
30-40% de los colegas está enfermo de
covido hoy día están aislados en
recuperándose y necesitábamos como país
una política que ayude a que la
población se vacune mejor y se proteja
de toda esta pandemia Lamentablemente la
política que emplea el gobierno ha sido
muy débil no ha llegado con general
credibilidad en la población y hoy día
lamentamos que hay una población muy
fuerte que se opone a la vacunación y
también se pusieron duramente a la
carnetización nos ha causado
nos está causando mucha preocupación
porque todavía el país no ha alcanzado
los indicadores suficientes de
vacunación
Cuál es la opinión de Ramiro Cordero
también en la ciudad de la paz el
gobierno se dio ante la presión de los
grupos sociales de la presión de la
sociedad de estos grupos antivacuna anti
experimentación o que simplemente Están
en contra de la obligatoriedad
Muy buenas tardes primero que nada no
somos grupos antivacun yo soy médico y
estoy a favor de la vacuna pero en este
caso imagínense lo que dice el colega
40% de los médicos están de baja pero el
100% de los médicos están vacunados con
la primera segunda y hasta con la
tercera dosis por lo tanto estamos
conscientes aquellas personas que no
queremos vacunarnos diferente a
antivacuna que la vacunación que están
haciendo No resuelve el problema de
contagio primero segundo
esta situación de los micrón de este
coronavirus tampoco tiene una relación
directa en el sentido de que por ejemplo
dicen que en Bolivia tienen la secuencia
genómica del virus Pues si la tuvieran
tendríamos una porción de lo que
necesitamos saber para ver si esto que
nos quieran inyectar es adecuado es
correcto y es científico lo cual no es
porque porque hasta el día de hoy ni hay
secuencia económica ni siquiera sabemos
que la vacuna protege a los mismos
vacunados y por tanto la otra situación
estamos en un limbo en una incertidumbre
médica donde en Bolivia se maneja mucho
la improvisación médica por lo tanto
como vamos a hacer que la población
confíe en el empirismo médico científico
Esto no es correcto nosotros necesitamos
respuestas Necesitamos saber de parte de
estas autoridades que están haciendo
unas leyes tan raras decir primero de
Cara a la ciencia a nosotros como
médicos que la prueba pcr no es
específica para diagnosticar nada
segundo reitero la vacunación está dando
de baja a sus propios vacunados
40% del gremio médico está de baja
Entonces qué Esperanza para el pueblo
doctor Cordero hago la aclaración Que en
ningún momento lo estoy llamando a usted
antivacunas de hecho la pregunta iba en
otra dirección era para conocer su
opinión sobre esta medida del gobierno
de levantar el pase sanitario y englobé
en la pregunta los diferentes sectores
que se han quejado en torno a esta
medida que impuso el gobierno del
presidente Arce en ningún momento estoy
señalando usted como antivacuna Pero
gracias por hacer la aclaración y
especificar también Cuál es su postura
frente a este a este tema así nos queda
todo muy claro y más despejado para
empezar el debate usted toca un punto
importante y es la improvisación médica
que está viviendo Bolivia qué crítica si
usted Entonces a las autoridades
bolivianas
sobre el manejo que le están dando a la
pandemia del Coby 19 además Bolivia
tiene la particularidad que tuvo
elecciones en la mitad de el proceso del
desarrollo de la pandemia y hubo cambio
de gobierno y también hubo cambio de
estrategia por el cambio de la
presidencia Cómo ve usted que ha sido el
manejo
hasta ahora el manejo no es profesional
ni del punto de vista médico primero
ellos dicen que en la primera segunda
tercera ola por ejemplo los índices de
letalidad eran altos sí eran altos por
qué Porque el protocolo de tratamiento
médico emanado desde la OMS estaba
equivocado si no hubiesen habido las 70
autopsias que hizo el doctor pascual
evacua en Italia hubiesen continuado con
el alto grado de letalidad segundo
Nosotros sí estamos conscientes que en
Bolivia en la primera segunda tercera
ola logramos disminuir los índices de
incidencia del coronavirus gracias al
dióxido de cloro una solución que no
aceptan mis colegas médicos porque
porque Sencillamente
incide en sus ingresos económicos
de seguir una una práctica médica donde
se mantiene enfermos de por vida y en
este momento sabiendo que la vacuna es
experimental que hay ahora mil estudios
que hablan de contraindicaciones ellos
persisten en mantener sus errores y no
responsabilizarse ante la población como
gobierno
Fernando Romero también allí en la
ciudad de la paz bueno varias preguntas
para usted primero su opinión en torno
al manejo que le ha dado el gobierno
boliviano al manejo de la pandemia como
tal a la gestión del presidente Arce
veíamos ya lo mencionaba yo imponen el
pase sanitario para entrar en uso a
partir del primero lo postergan para el
26 Y optan por levantarlo usted ya nos
comentaba al respecto Qué opinión tiene
en torno a lo que dice el Señor Cordero
Bueno a la par de de que no se planificó
a la par de que no hubo un plan de
vacunación en forma coordinada con los
diferentes sectores a la par de que el
propio vicepresidente pues hasta lo
último de Hace unos días nada más recién
se vacuna junto con otros senadores y
diputados del gobierno bueno vino otro
mensaje y un mensaje mal interpretado
por la población ese mensaje en el que
no era necesario vacunarse en que la
medicina alternativa y otras opciones
terapéuticas eran suficientes eso generó
también un problema grave en la
población la población al final quedó
desinformada y al ver una información
tan incoherente de parte del gobierno su
propio vicepresidente de reitero fue el
último y obligado a vacunarse bueno ha
generado esa duda razonada en la
población y nosotros hoy día estamos en
medio de una en la que a la población
Tratamos de decirle que una cosa no se
opone a la otra una forma de tratamiento
no se opone al otro se complementa en
forma adecuada Y por supuesto en base a
lectura de indicadores que en la que se
ha visto que la vacunación y el uso de
otras medidas más complementarias han
bajado Los indicadores de letalidad de
mortalidad y de complicaciones esa
creemos que es la tarea a la que debería
ir el gobierno hoy día pero pues no se
ve esa intención de las autoridades no
se ve esa intención de llegar a la
población de abrir más espacios de
diálogo de buscar una concertación tanto
así que no se ve que se dio a una
presión muy fuerte de la sociedad pero
sin plantear una solución no se plantea
una forma alterna al Canal de vacunación
por ejemplo y esto nos pone en esta
situación de estar ahí contra la pared
de no saber qué rumbo va a tomar el país
de aquí para adelante hace poco el
presidente dio mensaje a la nación
esperábamos que toque el tema
esperábamos que de una luz en el
Horizonte pero tampoco lo hizo y hoy día
la situación hace así de compleja y
difícil como lo plantea también el
doctor Gary doctor Romero
con esto que usted nos explica Entonces
cuál podría haber sido la idea del
gobierno para imponer este pase
sanitario buscaba sin duda alguna
aumentar la vacunación como fue lo que
se evidenció en los primeros días de
enero los centros de vacunación con
bastante afluencia de ciudadanos tanto
así que luego el gobierno dijo No un
momento lo aplazamos para el 26 porque
hay muchas personas tratando de
vacunarse para obtener el pase y no
estamos dando abasto cuál era entonces
la estrategia del gobierno o la
estrategia le salió mal
es correcto el punto era que esa medida
de la vacunación que debía haber sido
preparada perdón de carnet de vacunación
que debía haberse preparado con meses de
anticipación en el debate análisis sobre
todo generando credibilidad en la
población no se hizo y al verse con
millones de vacunas millones de dosis
muchas de ellas en riesgo de vencimiento
que en unas semanas muchas dosis de la
vacuna moderna por ejemplo coren riesgo
de ya perder su su vida útil antes de
riesgo bueno no le quedó otra al
ministro de salud que imponer un carnet
Pero si tú impones una medida tan dura
sin debate sin coordinación sin acuerdos
Pues el resultado se veía venir en una
posición dura de la población que
terminó en retrocediendo en el gobierno
una medida que bien trabajada podía
haber sido importante lamentablemente no
se fue por ahí y hoy día te reitero no
hay plan no hay una una política del
gobierno no hay que rumbo vamos a tomar
Aparentemente vamos a volver a la
improvisación a ver qué conviene
políticamente a una gestión de gobierno
y bueno sacarle algún rédito a la
enfermedad en esa medida un punto en
común de los invitados de improvisación
médica pasó a preguntarle al doctor
Cordero por este pase de la discordia el
pase sanitario que generó protestas en
diferentes ciudades de Bolivia sobre
todo en las principales la paz
Cochabamba y Santa Cruz precisamente el
departamento de Santa Cruz es donde más
están concentrando
los reportes de casos de Kobe 19 por lo
menos en las últimas semanas o en los
últimos días ha habido un incremento de
casos allí doctor Cordero cree usted que
el gobierno impuso este pase sanitario
como una medida para obligar a la gente
de manera indirecta a vacunarse y no le
salió la estrategia
bueno la carnetización es una coartación
de la libertad de las personas y esto lo
hizo todo a nivel político es decir
ellos compraron vacunas ellos dijeron
vamos a vacunar y vamos a hacer los
líderes de la vacunación sin contar con
que las personas
tienen capacidad de respuesta y eso es
lo que generamos ante tanta adversidad
por las vacunas
ante tanta situación irregular por
vacunas acá se hizo una manifestación
multitudinaria que bajamos desde el alto
de la ciudad a la plena ciudad y
bloqueamos todo diciendo no queremos
vacuna no queremos carnetización de la
vacuna porque tenemos con nosotros
medicinas alternativas que han dado
respuesta tenemos el dióxido de oro y
tenemos la medicina ancestral boliviana
el haber hecho un manual y ponerlo ahí
en la mesa y decir aquí está la medicina
ancestral no es algo que signifique
respeto a lo que nosotros manejamos como
país por lo tanto no podemos estar de
acuerdo en políticas de gobierno que
excedan aquel límite de la libertad de
las personas de elegir de la capacidad
de pensar y sobre todo de definir lo que
quiere para su propia existencia esto es
fundamental
fundamental un derecho fundamental
doctor Romero La libertad y la capacidad
de decidir que quiere uno hacer con el
manejo de una situación como la pandemia
aquí se le están violando algunas
libertades a los ciudadanos cuando se
les estaba imponiendo este tipo de
carnetización el uso del pase sanitario
para poderse movilizar y hago la
pregunta porque el presidente Arce ha
sido muy claro él dijo levantamos la
medida pero de ser necesario en
cualquier momento volverá a imponer la
medida de obligatoriedad de presentar un
carnet de vacunación para poder ingresar
a sitios públicos se están violando
libertades
correcto correcto de para nosotros así
poner en una balanza dos escenarios no
el país tiene los indicadores más altos
de letalidad es donde más médicos han
fallecido en toda América Latina en las
tres horas anteriores Y también en la
población en relación a número de
pobladores somos tenemos el país con más
mortalidad letalidad en la población
entonces ahí estaba el problema grave
pero ahí también estaba la violación de
derechos ahí estaba lo que perfectamente
hice el autor Cordero que derechos
básicos que están en la Constitución
claramente establecidos se estaban
vulnerando con esta medida y no había
coherencia en la forma en la que se le
implementó de un día para el otro
obligara a una población a tomar esta
medida que de otra forma implementada
coordinada consensuada Quién sabe podía
haber dado a mejores resultados Por
supuesto que estaba vulnerando la y no
había más remedio que parar esta este
abuso este exceso de autoridad y anular
la canalización que sea obligatoria me
refiero a eso pero el problema la herida
sigue abierta el problema está ahí no lo
hemos resuelto no hay solución todavía
número alto de personas expuestas a la
enfermedad son la saturación de los
hospitales y a la crisis que pasamos en
el país
doctor Romero continuó con usted ya le
doy la palabra doctor Cordero para
continuar en el debate pero quería
preguntarle al doctor Romero usted le
apuesta un poco más a la medicina
tradicional a lo que se está digamos
promoviendo a nivel internacional que
son el uso de estas vacunas algunos
protocolos algunos cuidados pero ustedes
boliviano Y qué piensa usted de la
medicina tradicional de su país de esos
protocolos que menciona el doctor
Cordero que existen allí de estas
tradiciones que el doctor Cordero dice
han dado algunos resultados Qué opinión
tiene usted
Totalmente de acuerdo esta pandemia ha
puesto en la mesa a una medicina
ancestral milenaria que tiene nuestra
cultura y que ha mostrado un importante
como un tratamiento ante la enfermedad
pero también nos podemos dejar de lado
que la mortalidad que ha causado sin la
vacuna el covid fue altísima y con la
vacuna hoy día ha bajado en forma
estadísticamente demostrable Entonces
nosotros creemos que hoy día es la
complementariedad una con otra y eso
sumará fuerzas y el resultado será
importante para la población
complemento y sumar fuerzas doctor
Cordero no le parece a usted que esa
puede ser la fórmula complementar esa
medicina ancestral boliviana que usted
mencionaba y la medicina actual los
avances de la ciencia los avances que se
pueden estar haciendo con estas vacunas
experimentales que sabemos Y tenemos
Claro que no va a evitar que nos dé Kobe
19 pero sí que tenga Tal vez un índice
de letalidad menor y que la afectación
en el organismo sea menor a lo que
presenta el Kobe 19 cuando se cuando la
persona se contagia y no tiene ningún
tipo de inmunización usted que piensa
porque atacar ese tipo de Medicina
cuando también ha demostrado tener
resultados
pues mire los resultados no sé dónde los
ve porque países como Israel como Gran
Bretaña su gran problema es los
vacunados en nosotros también se está
viendo esto que el menor proporción
porque felizmente no tenemos el mayor
porcentaje de vacunación en nuestra
población por lo tanto teniendo Además
nosotros el antecedente de en las tres
primeras olas y Le repito de haber hecho
descender la curva de incidencia del
coronavirus en base al dióxido de cloro
y las medicinas ancestrales debemos
tener el suficiente valor para apoyarnos
en ellas y mantener la situación de
voluntariedad aquella persona que desee
vacunarse voluntariedad que yo un
término en el cual también estoy en
contra porque significa que si esa
persona voluntariamente se vacunó
volunta relativamente también puede
tener un efecto adverso
inclusive llegar a la muerte y esto es
donde estoy en contra porque de esta
manera el gobierno
simplemente se lava las manos y no
acepta la responsabilidad por una vacuna
experimental que ellos sí saben que es
de carácter experimental donde hasta el
día de hoy no tenemos idea exacta de los
efectos adversos de largo plazo mediano
plazo ni siquiera de aquí a un año Por
lo tanto yo estoy de acuerdo en lo
voluntario Pero debe haber una
responsabilidad de parte del gobierno
respecto a aquellos cuadros de
adversidad y fomentar más de lo que está
haciendo la medicina tradicional
boliviana y el dióxido de cloro tenemos
decreto tenemos ley y sin embargo no se
aplica y Esto va en contra de su
política que es simplemente mirar hacia
afuera pero no Mirar los valores que
tenemos adentro esto es en contra de lo
que somos como pueblo como país
doctor Cordero habla usted de
responsabilidad por parte del Estado qué
grado de responsabilidad entonces debe
asumir qué posiciones debe asumir el
gobierno explicando su posición
interesante profundizar ahí
Mire
las vacunas no tienen hasta el día de
hoy en Efe estudiados efectos
secundarios en un año tres años cinco
años y más allá
hablan que por ejemplo no hay efecto en
cuanto a posibilidad de fecundación
futura Y cómo hacen han adivinado
Entonces esto es donde yo digo el
gobierno está tomando una vacuna
experimental como algo real como algo
que tiene ya estudios realizados y eso
no es así acaba la facer de decir que no
tienen estudios respecto a las vacunas
con niños respecto a problemas
cardiovasculares o pulmonares por lo
tanto
yo sigo manteniendo la situación respeto
al coronavirus como tal pero deberían
haber medidas preventivas más
importantes para para atender a esta
situación uno es el dióxido de cloro y
otros son las plantas naturales doctor
Romero pasó con usted a poner aquí sobre
la mesa lo que acaba de decir el doctor
Cordero sobre esta responsabilidad sobre
esta falta de estudios y profundización
en las investigaciones un tema que
llevamos ya debatiendo muchos meses
desde que inició la pandemia del Coby 19
y desde que llegaron al mercado las
vacunas por parte de las farmacéuticas
su opinión
bueno está claro que cualquier
procedimiento
que debe implementarse en base a una
política de salud tiene que venir con un
respaldo científico estudios darle
seguridad a la población Totalmente de
acuerdo sin embargo también entendemos
que Así de rápido como apareció un Gohan
y la alta mortalidad que nos causó
obligada a implementar medidas heroicas
también la entendemos como sector y a la
par de implementar la vacuna Las
investigaciones que se han hecho
nosotros el sector salud ha recibido y
Como hace dos años la primera dosis de
vacunación y no hemos visto gracias a
Dios no hay problemas trombóticos ni
problemas de guillain Barré ni problemas
de hipersensibilidad Entonces ese tipo
de estudios deben haberse acompañado
pero seriamente realizados por parte de
las autoridades porque ellos tienen
todos los recursos económicos para eso
no lo hicieron y hoy día estamos ahí a
criterios irregulares
un poco respaldados pocos validados
llevando adelante el plan de atención y
de lucha contra el covid es una
debilidad de la gestión de gobierno
esperamos Que tengan el tiempo
suficiente de replantearse esto y puedan
reconducirlo Pero como se den las cosas
hoy día en el país estamos lejos de esa
situación doctor Romero sé que usted no
es politólogo ni experto en el tema pero
desde su punto de vista médico y desde
su perspectiva de la pandemia del manejo
que ha tenido allí en Bolivia esto le
pasará factura a nivel político al
presidente arce y a su gobierno que
piensa
Sí sí totalmente totalmente en las
últimas movilizaciones que fueron
multitudinarias una gran parte de
quienes estaban movilizados eran
militantes son militantes del partido de
gobierno muchos sectores que son la
columna vertebral de su apoyo político
que tienen en la comunidad han estado
inmovilizados y le va a pasar le está
pasando ya una un costo político alto al
gobierno del presidente y yo creo que en
la misma medida en que esto vaya
avanzando y agudizándose porque te
reitero no ha habido una solución de
fondo en esto los hospitales ya nos
damos no podemos responder a tanto
paciente bueno va a irse debilitando la
gestión del gobierno eso con seguridad
que va a ocurrir Ojalá que eso obligue a
las autoridades reitero a replantearse
esto y reconducir esta débil lucha
contra la pandemia el doctor Romero al
doctor Cordero le preguntó no por la
presidencia la gestión del mandatario
sino por la gestión del ministro de
salud por el señor auza también le
pasará factura esto llevará un cambio
esto generará un precedente de cara al
futuro para mejorar las condiciones el
sistema de salud de Bolivia que ya venía
afectado antes de la pandemia
Sí porque la acción que tiene el señor
ministro de salud en Bolivia simplemente
es de capricho Porque siendo el médico
no tiene consideración de de
básicas situaciones por interés del
pueblo por lo tanto tiene que haber un
cambio en su política y tiene que haber
un cambio a favor de las personas
fomentando prácticamente lo que vuelva a
decir la prevención del coronavirus en
base a las plantas medicinales y en base
al dióxido de cloro nosotros tenemos en
este momento
alta cantidad de enfermos hablan y dicen
son los no vacunados Pero sabemos que
entre los médicos
vacunados hay una alta incidencia de
baja por enfermedad por lo tanto
reitero siempre lo mismo tiene que
cambiar la política hacia la forma de
prevención y una vez que hagamos esto
encaremos como un país subdesarrollado
encaremos de mejor manera el hecho de
solo repartir tabletas de parte de la
medicina oficial doctor Cordero
prevención pero es que ya estamos en el
medio de la pandemia llevamos ya dos
años en medio de esta situación era poco
previsible que esto fuera convertirse en
el escenario en el que estamos ahora
cuando empezaron los primeros brotes se
empujan como hablar de prevención en ese
caso
porque nosotros en este corto tiempo
demostramos que teníamos en nuestro
poder un producto capaz de neutralizar
estos picos en un país subdesarrollado
como somos yo le digo lo siguiente y
esto está en nuestra historia
contemporánea de hace poco la primera
segunda y tercera ola nosotros como
Bolivia fuimos un espejo de irrealidad
para nuestros vecinos fronterizos donde
estaban atosigados y ahogándose con
casos de coronavirus y nosotros
estábamos tranquilos pasándola de
digamos en una forma cómoda porque
porque entre nuestras armas Había algo
que nunca habíamos contado que era el
dióxido de cloro que felizmente se
masificó se tomó de forma indiscriminada
como está sucediendo ahora con una
limitación que antes las universidades
al ver el desarrollo de las de la
situación empezaron a producir pero por
acciones del gobierno posteriormente en
este momento solo hay una universidad
que produce dióxido de cloro Por eso
para mí personalmente es que tenemos el
repunte siempre tendremos oportunidad de
hacer prevención pero con los productos
adecuados y la dirección médica correcta
doctor Romero no puedo dejar de
preguntarle por el dióxido de cloro Qué
opinión tiene usted al respecto la
mencionada a lo largo del programa
reiteradas ocasiones el doctor Cordero
sí correcto el doctor Cordero relata las
tres anteriores o las que hemos tenido
en el país
estábamos indefensos no había
absolutamente capacidad de respuesta del
sistema de salud y ahí surgió el dióxido
de cloro Ahí vimos a Muchos pacientes
colegas utilizar la medicación Nosotros
también la hemos utilizado como parte de
la opción que tenemos de
complementariedad de reitero así le
entendemos al dióxido y ha habido
interesantes resultados
de su efectividad sin embargo
no se puede nada más darle como la
salida alternativa única a una opción
terapéutica creemos que el dióxido de
cloro tiene que ser estudiado más
todavía tiene que ser validado por
protocolos mucho más rigurosos y ojalá
Dios quiera un día que tenga la
suficiente base evidencia científica
para que sea un elemento fuerte dentro
del protocolo de tratamiento y también
de prevención de la enfermedad por ahora
nosotros lo tuvemos al dióxido como una
complementariedad del del tratamiento
dentro por junto además claro con la
medicina alternativa que tiene nuestro
país la medicina originaria que es muy
fuerte en Bolivia creemos que trabajando
en esas tres líneas lo que es la
medicina basada en la vacunación la
medicina en el dióxido de la medicina
alternativa el país puede ganar mucho y
tener un fuerte protocolo de atención y
prevención por ahora tampoco hemos
avanzado en esa línea y bueno ojalá Dios
quiera que algún momento podamos dar
pasos adelante protocolo de acción y
prevención que no tiene en este momento
muy bien definido según lo que está
sucediendo allí y según lo que ustedes
describen no es mi opinión es lo que
puede uno organizar en este rompecabezas
con las ideas que ustedes nos dan desde
la ciudad de la paz recta final para el
programa conclusiones quiero que sean
los dos por favor de lo que puede
suceder en Bolivia en este escenario en
donde vuelve y se mezcla la pandemia con
lo político con las decisiones y la
reversa de muchas de estas decisiones
como lo hemos visto en los últimos días
allí en este país suramericano qué va a
pasar con Bolivia con este tema de la
pandemia comienzo con el doctor Cordero
bien lo que nosotros tenemos que hacer
es fortificar nuestra posición respecto
a las medicinas complementarias e
integrativas 1 la base para mí y en
nuestro en encarar el futuro es la
prevención que podemos hacer aún
teniendo el coronavirus con nosotros
como compañero habitual pero no tenemos
otra alternativa doctor Romero
rápidamente su conclusión
estamos muy preocupados si no cambia de
rumbo la visión política el actual
político del gobierno y viene una quinta
ola con una mutación más agresiva del
virus Bolivia va a ser una carnicería va
a ser un desastre porque estamos
indefensos no tenemos a que aferrarnos
como población de haber un cambio de
rumbo urgente de otra manera la crisis
que viene va a ser fatal doctor Romero y
doctor Cordero en la ciudad de la paz en
Bolivia Muchas gracias por este análisis
para la audiencia de France 24 en toda
América Latina ustedes Muchas gracias
por la sintonía y Pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]